do you ever feel bored in life yeah I've
got the perfect solution for you become
a certified a pewdiepie bro for a small
payment of $5 a month you will
experience happiness like no other or if
you're broke
turning off adblock will also do you'll
be provided with the finest
state-of-the-art entertainment including
horror deep [ __ ] loud screaming [ __ ]
anyway Jesus object my name is Jeff
lots of get my name yeah subscribe today
you will regret it
hey how's it goin rust family friendly
Felix here anyone still watching today
we're going to go through some more
commercial you guys really liked the
last video so we're doing it again
whenever definitely yeah me I'm awaiting
my bet I did yes now there were some
objects that I reviewed in the last
video that didn't make it I didn't get
the item thing time and I would just
like to review one of my favorite one
right off the bat of the booty pop booty
pop I've scavenged the internet I've
searched the deep end and I got the
booty pop I'm wearing kind of baggy
pants today so I don't know
family-friendly no don't no sexual
intended okay if you look at me sexually
I want you to click away right now
because he's not family-friendly go
watch Casey alright there we go
that's pretty good [ __ ] it these oh my
god it's like a diaper yeah I can wear
it you can also wear it at the Brys to
pose how did it like it just feel quite
nice I'm not gonna lie it feels like a
nice [ __ ] ass I would love to have
this ass I know I sound like I'm joking
I'm not joking this is an amazing after
that it feels great 100 percent under on
eclis amazing product here Hollywood's
hottest new trade secret I get 100
inside of bra enhances booty pop panties
are now revolutionising women's
undergarments giving you sexy curves in
the ultimate list I've seen on TV why is
it no matter what you do the view is
never big enough for you it's just all a
big blur it it's just I can't tell what
it is it's all just a big ol blur got no
clue one big sex could be jackspehn
asses [ __ ] for all I know a little
bit like covergirl it looks like I read
lips what you're looking at emojis what
a dumb [ __ ] glasses have you heard of
them what cutie is reading glasses
that's amazing let's see how the here
reactors phone come on and it's just
like it's occurring instant clarity why
were reading glasses with that you can
look somewhat normal in when you can
we're [ __ ] working good look at that
look at that guy who would walk around
like that I would never been able to do
it without oh my god this is amazing
I would never have oh my god and it's
amazing my ice I can finally see I can
finally feel this is actually really
cool do I look cool I feel like I look
real fresh real nice real tight hello
ladies zoom in on my [ __ ] eye pimple
that came in yesterday thank you it's
style now from having my way the world's
first now
solution invented by a woman invested by
a walnut gee I wasn't sure before I
don't like it when men do it but now I
might actually like it hot stylist
magazines and TV shows are raving about
them so just tuck them in you can just
tuck anything in what's the boy genius
it's not yes but here's the real
question
if I order do I get two of them double
the offer absolutely free every [ __ ]
time every [ __ ] time they do this
they throw in two of them for no [ __ ]
reason you know I don't need eight of
them I guess I need sixteen of them if
we go back to big vision I swear they'll
throw in a double one as well protect it
carry case free but I hang on to help
your big [ __ ] hang on hang on what
justify or lanyard Oh offer really clear
running guys to gather beer oh look at
that you get another one I guess I
really need two of them so I can I can
have a 400 percent vision so I can wear
them double layers you know what I'm
saying every what kind of sales trick is
that if you subscribe now you won't only
get to subscribe for free you get to
subscribe again
for free you just hit subscribe and we
subscribe twice try it out it's free
Lindsey introduces us to the newest
arrival to the Magic Bullet family oh
it's the Magic Bullet I've seen this
done many times thank you and mercy so
will your gift Oh me I'm waiting for a
special delivery oh my god the cringe I
wanna I want to kill me this is good
this is good stuff okay and it's just in
time special delivery for Johnny
why did you ring the door if you were
just gonna let yourself in any way
she'll delivery for Jenny oh come on and
Mick just set it right down there on the
counter that's what he did you [ __ ]
[ __ ] nice package
come on guys come on in and take a look
at this gather learning me you need to
check this out let me guess he's gonna
be super-impressed later
is the baby bullet what is real it have
redesigned the blade the motor and the
side into the perfect combination for
making perfect purees for the best baby
food making system if you've ever seen
oh I thought it would be safe for babies
to use I was like oh so I can't stick my
face in the blender anymore well I'm not
going to buy it then it's a useless
product hey he's still not impressed
what is wrong with him what the [ __ ]
almost 20 jars and that's justice what
he's genuinely bored it's not like he
plays the board character the real
question here is do you get two of them
call now and get a second baby bullet
system for free call right now I need to
call right now I need two of them
shocking bullying while I'm blending
what do you granule my ha ha ha ha
[Laughter]
already oh my god yes
who [ __ ] cracks like that you [ __ ]
idiot wait until you see what I had I
really hope this woman spent her entire
life investment on this piece of [ __ ]
product because I hate her already I'm
sorry
thank you cracker now you can crack as
quickly and effortless I just imagined
she was like I need to design a product
to castrate my man because he cheated on
me whenever ice cracking eggs it'd be a
mess on install button that's on the
counter well maybe you just didn't learn
how to do it properly
[Music]
my new easy cracker wedge is a snap
andressa frenzy and in the cradle and
Stewie how do you begin the visit well
we're going to test it out we're going
to test it out because I have one I
happen to have an easy cracker right
here very nice but boy do I get to get
crack it in order now I had this for a
while I'm actually genuinely excited to
see if this one works
you can tell all right well that looks
dirty
I guess I'll crack in the package so how
does it work oh [ __ ] you know what this
looks pretty cool because it's like
separate sent someone definitely stuck
this in the wrong place
you just know that someone did not know
it wasn't me okay it wasn't me
this is the first this is my virgin I
don't want to spell I don't want to make
a mess so I'm a little nervous
Wow
[Music]
that really works doesn't [ __ ] crack
this just seems like it seems like a lot
[ __ ] harder than just cracking the
[ __ ] hang it still doesn't [ __ ]
work
what a [ __ ] yeah it's and here's also
like an ancient trick I don't know if
you know but it's like a wizard you just
do this actually you know what she makes
a great [ __ ] case I was horrible you
were right Wendy you were right I was
wrong I take it all back I did get out
back leave a like and I'll if you want
me to do more of these think it's really
fun I enjoy laughing at people making
bad business positions you know it's
something wonderful about it so leave
like you enjoyed and let me know if you
want more check out my other video that
I did on this